okay ready okay be careful i did have
the dunkin donuts snack and bacon this
morning okay ready i didn't have
breakfast okay okay okay
[Applause]
three two one
oh my god you look exactly the same yeah
you do too you're just taller thank you
thank you
thank you
hi
okay cool
good it's been 16 16 years 16 years yeah
yeah i honestly never thought i would
hear from her again but in elementary
school i was mean and angus was annoying
yes
pretty good yeah that's pretty accurate
yeah
i think all throughout grade school we
were friends up until i left that school
and i left the school in
sixth grade to go to a different school
uptown so i never saw english again up
until today well what moments do you
remember if that i don't remember
let me think oh my god
i mean i remember our first kiss
happened when we were six years old in
first grade i remember my dad had just
taught me the word immature
i didn't really know what it meant but i
just want to use it and so angus was
doing something something annoying and i
was like angus you are so immature and
then he looked at me and he goes
i can be mature and then he kissed me
and i was like all right this was my
very first kiss yeah i don't know
why i thought like being mature meant
kissing like i try to act like i meant
to do that this totally makes sense but
inside i was like
why did i do that
yeah i did not have a crush on angus
this was very random because i had a
crush on a different kid
wait wait wait
what's wrong
yeah
did it feel transformational for you
um
it did not
being like the only black person in my
class i had so many other things to
focus on
nine percent asian yeah literally i
watched disney movies over and over and
over again so i had this idea of like
what romance was what a kiss was but it
seemed unattainable for me because
i was just the only black kid and like
people just treated me very differently
so not really transformational but like
you know a cute moment was this your
first kiss
uh yeah i'm not sure so there was
someone else like was it wait tell me
are you kidding me
it wasn't cause she was tall and i was
short
i mean i kissed both of you so like
obviously i didn't mind it
that's true okay i don't think when i
was younger i really thought about like
what my first kiss would be like you
know kisses are just lips touching each
other there's so many moments in our
lives that are really monumental like
the first time you get a house the first
time you graduate from school right
there's no idea of virginity for that
but there is for sex it does shape you
but like i'm not like
you know a whole different girl on the
last day of school someone gave me a
disposable camera and so they're like
take a picture with every single person
in the class so you'll remember this and
so i did that and i kept it in a book
and they're little notes from everyone
in the class yeah i haven't seen this
book so okay
are you ready okay okay ready
do you remember this
not at all okay well there's a picture
of us in there this is so cute yeah and
there's like a little note that you
wrote in it oh oh my god
looking back it's never
nice to see yourself oh no you look so
cute stop with the glasses oh the
glasses yes
yes come on harry potter i looked like
this into high school too you did okay
yeah can you see that
oh my god am i crying are you they're
little notes that's like all the kids
wrote you can read yours i actually
don't know what it says
how bad is it
buy addis okay
period
damn
i picked in the first grade dinner yeah
i think you did did i peek in the first
grade no definitely definitely not
i guess so we're strangers to each other
in a way but i don't see you as someone
that like i don't know yeah exactly
exactly we essentially grew up together
mm-hmm so we'll always have that what
are your thoughts on kissing again
yeah i'm down
you're like when you're about to like
kisses yeah i mean you know it's like
when you like go up a roller coaster
like you know it's gonna pop off but
you're like waiting for it to pop off
because we're not like six anymore i
know
it's been 20 years because i'm 26. are
you 26. oh yeah it's been 20 years it's
been 20 years since we last kissed
that's crazy i hope i'm a better kisser
too
okay ready okay be careful i did have
the dunkin donuts snacking bacon this
morning okay ready i didn't have
breakfast okay okay
what's different though yeah what are
you doing after this
[Music]
no no like you said practice makes
perfect yes exactly exactly that was
she's like a kisser yeah
a first kiss is definitely not a
universal cognitive modifier right but
they can be sensational
no regrets period